winter olympics getting excited I think
so yeah no you reacted way too late for
that day there was a noticeable gap for
your leg
uh and then we're on TV I sensed it you
sensed it Eddie
okay you're not true Americans know the
Winter Olympics are coming and it's been
reported that they're gonna be handing
out over 100,000 condoms in the Olympic
Village yeah yeah after hearing about it
Americans everywhere said now that's the
show we want to watch that's the show
see ya
you know those athletes right freezing
cold gets it on yeah how'd you add
freezing cold it's an added wrinkle yeah
no miss you said you were looking for a
job
and you'll be the first to tell you you
don't want to be here out go ahead you
had this look like free free today Nancy
Pelosi spoke on the House floor in
support of immigrants who don't want to
be sent back to their home countries
then Melania Trump spoke on behalf of
immigrants who want to be said back
just wants to get away from her husband
now-now-now when you were silent during
that whole olympics thing i knew i had
your number then and i got your number
now the makers of Crocs
that's right Crocs the makers of Crocs
that's right you heard me man Crocs I'm
doing this for me now the makers the
makers of Crocs this is number four
thousand man if you don't think I'm
phoning it in now I always said the day
I get to 4,000 yeah I'm gonna be a real
dick
[Applause]
she's gonna get my job before this night
is out the the makers of Crocs have come
out with a special high-fashion pair
that sells for eight hundred and fifty
dollars true story yeah yeah crock said
the upscale sandals are the perfect shoe
for wealthy men who were tired of
getting laid
[Applause]
you